hey there folks Chris waters here
welcome you to the gamespot studios and
our titanfall beta the pros way in round
table as you can see I'm flanked by a
bunch of gamers here what's up guys I'm
Tyler T people child part of complexity
gaming I have the most championships in
call of duty my name is Brett also known
as nated I've been a professional video
game player for nine years primarily in
Halo Aaron Sampson here producer a game
spot and I'm Ryan schubert also of games
but this here I hear the grunts always
go down here so you see them right there
to the wall she consists always
consistent with where they go and now
you have a line devil here roll them
down and now this one of those
situations where there um I usually try
to go the Cinemax like you like we got
tight abs it's the best thing big to be
learnt that the options you know you get
into some tough points although there I
of course if you're at the smart pistol
see because now the that raises the
question to me of the kind of lock on
time and smart pistol evacuee weapon i
think we discussed free live stream but
haven't really got the target an enemy
pilot it locks on to to a head shot so
once you've gotten three or you know
your bullets loaded up on an enema enemy
player that's gonna be an instant kill
from the smart pistol but of course it
takes time to do that what do you guys
think about the smart pistol I haven't
really used it its cuz it seems newbies
to me it seems to me right it's like ah
I could I can point my gun at an enemy I
don't need help right I definitely agree
like they did halo for example
where people could create their own of
course this is a familiar game mode to
all of you you know Stan capture the
point how are you feeling like it's its
manifestation in the titanfall beta here
is is is shaping up is this hair anybody
tighten if it's one of the internal
capture points mm-hmm like where you
might want to call down your Titan and
set it to auto patrol outside exactly
you know we gotta tighten at all at the
charlee we're polar your Ender's guy in
the roof of Charlie you know or you
might want to leave your Titan behind
that seeing on on fracture and just let
it do guard mode that's kind of an early
warning system while you're working on
be yep watch your back you got it you
got a guy on your back things are
getting heated here at capture point B
regret its contestant oh we got a bunch
of tiny cottam koo got a little tail and
we process still alive and kicking and
holding that point down our team off
once again we're pretty good as greeters
alright be like a little robot posse
what just happened that was waiting fire
got a lot of damage yeah and that
carbine with that scope is especially
with the scope gonna get its iOS you
keep editor to be an hour if they gots
hang on the back of the lab when I can
you're standing at me using sort of that
for grand juries like that packet
sniffer ferc that shows this the
skeleton out to go on foot chasing after
the pilot prioritizing that even though
there's a titan on the ground nice oh I
think I thinking more of like an even
match I think Titans are perfectly easy
to get but I feel like in be sure that
that would be
sir at that time on that field is too
long for people are always kind of
camping in the fields as I even arrived
if it like extends yeah you just we're
just shredding them here at be but
because I guess you're capping see right
now which is good because guys are down
by about 20 points here and the match is
coming to a close so let's see if you
can pull it out we're ematic we're gonna
get all yeah I got see everything take
your brother back while these guys focus
all their energy on snatching victory
they've even it out now and they've
taken over the lead awesome stuff I
don't mind you coach me enter to win one
of these and ruin a custom titanfall
controller just follow gamespot on
twitter one controller and i'm gonna go
ahead and say that it was my coaching
right at that moment you guys that have
brought you to help you turn the tide
you know you can thank me now this
there's no burn card for you gonna face
coaching but i think
you know maybe that's something they can
consider no no commander mode yet and
now you're just straight up defending
from the rooftop over there Tyler and
getting more comers that fairly long
distance with the carbine showing why
that carbine is so effective and why
maybe you know the DMR not getting
children as often because that carbine
is just so good at this no the other
going on out there
Thanks is all your Titans pouring fire
into it the second it comes man yep yeah
you definitely need a lot of Titan fire
on that thing to bring it down nicely
done on the five pillars got a day 95
kills yeah you were pretty well
shredding things up that was that we're
the mostly SMG that your face awesome
videos quarter yeah I tried to hold down
the be hard point from the majority of
the game because people always trying to
funnel to that metal one to control two
mm-hmm and I just played and you played
really well really then man Oh get all
the way up in this little nook ya sea
wall jumping so you can get all the way
up here this is my favorite place to
hang out in last Titan standing cuz you
get a vantage point of the whole map
yeah and maybe this is a good place to
hang out with the DMR although these
trees gonna block your avenues all right
I got one yeah I one in the back right I
got a couple of crap though we've got
wonderfully on Maidan with okay adam
lippes I don't feel good got him nice
work dried of you inject now watching
you mean to say I want to get away lose
all right it's mine it's ok we're doing
a little warm out here now uh enemy
pilot running around a little bit crazy
hipfire come on come on hit carbon gonna
over the country I got another one got
no one with the rocket where'd you go
boy gotcha how early more's the pilot Oh
smart pistol even better outsmarted
heavy hitter you zoom I'm out got to do
that Santa Jack he's coming for you
right there oh no brutal punch running
away
gay running bottle we do if we got one
more where there it is he's gonna be the
equalizer victory in I was back yep I'm
on the back going on that ruler on the
back I want to thank TP and needed for
coming on out and joining us on our
competitive stream here a program and as
well you Ryan Aaron much appreciate it
and thanks to all you folks for watching
hope you had a good time we'll see you
next time